welcome to this DW business special
asking who have sanctions against Russia
hit hardest almost as soon as Russia's
military rolled onto Ukrainian soil
Western allies began their own assault
they initiated a sanctions regime that
has now targeted Russia's banking sector
its aviation industry its energy exports
and its oligarchs but from the outset
Moscow has said it would only backfire
were they right who are the sanctions
hurting the most
or to answer those questions and plenty
more I'm joined by Alina rubakova deputy
chief Economist at The Institute of
international finance thanks a lot for
joining us Elena
thank you so much for having me
so to understand who the sanctions are
hurting the most we need an idea of
their impact on Russia and also their
impact on the west so is Russia
suffering under these sanctioned Selena
Russia is definitely suffering under the
sanctions and I really like your
question who is suffering the most well
Russia's most Progressive integrated
into the global economy parts of the
Russian industry are suffering the most
you know with Russia made a lot of
progress since the 90s will remember you
know integration into the global value
chains limited it may be however it's
exactly those industries that are being
heard by the sanctions and also we
should not forget that common people are
suffering from sanctions as well and
it's not because they said the West the
evil West is imposing sanctions on
Common People is because the authorities
of Russia have decided to reorient all
of their spending and efforts towards
the War Machine and insulation and
isolation from the global economy and
therefore the common people already have
been paying the price since the 2014.
so that's it Russia is growing
increasingly isolated Elena just stay
with us because I just want to play
something the US and the EU you know are
very Swift to turn to sanctions as a
tool to punish Russia for its invasion
of Ukraine in February but from the
outset the message from the Kremlin has
been that the West would come out worse
than the Russians
we can now confidently declare that
their policies with respect to Russia
have failed the strategy of economic
Blitzkrieg has proven unsuccessful and
the sanctions have scored their known
goal for their initiators
the rejection of Russian energy
resources means that systemically in the
long term Europe will become the region
with the highest cost of energy
resources in the world
such economic self-harm or suicide is of
course a domestic matter for the
European countries
described it as an own goal or an act of
self-harm the the sanctions have they
proven to be as such for Europe and the
United States in particular
well I think the act of self-harm
clearly has been on behalf of Russia we
were expecting gross more than three
percent this year there was a very
strong recovery last year of more than
four percent for Russia however there is
nobody who's forecasting positive growth
for Russia this year all next year what
is more worrisome is the potential
growth and you think about it
simplistically whether it's labor Supply
Capital stock productivity date and
digital economy I cannot put a Plus on
any of those components so we expect
even medium-term potential growth if I
could as an economist put a negative
number I would put a negative number on
that and it's hard to dispute it in
terms of the impact of Europe of course
Europe as it moved towards sort of
reducing domestic energy depression it
became more reliant on Russia on more
than 40 percent of energy Imports
depending on the component however it's
also very healthy for Europe to
diversify the sources of their strategic
energy supplies and that's what's
happening Also let's not forget the
beginning of the year the forecast of
doom day scenarios including for Germany
that should produce double-digit
contraction in the economy and we're not
seeing that the economy is standing we
have seen some reductions but we've also
seen incredible signs of substitution in
Germany and other countries away from
Russian energy
the aim of the sanctions wasn't just I
suppose to punish Russia but was also to
squeeze its ability to pay for the war
and hopefully bring it to an early end
but it does appear that that hasn't been
successful so far that Russia hasn't
been running out of the money it needs
to continue its assault on Ukraine
well I think that is linked partially to
unrealistic expectations and we flagged
it also a few years back that Russia has
pursued Fortress Russia's strategy since
2014 and although some analysts laughed
about it well it has proven at least
partially accurate you know they have
introduced inflation targeting cleaned
up the banking system introduced fiscal
policy rule where they saved extra
budgetary revenues with oil over 40
dollars per barrel so this extra money
that we're saving on the national
well-being fund so that we're preparing
maybe nobody knew for this specific War
but they were insulating and isolating
the economy since 2014. therefore
sanctions is not like flipping a switch
and suddenly Russia disintegrates no
it's a long-term strategy that needs to
be adjusted and also carefully
implemented so for example we've seen
contraction and imports uh to from by
Russia in the beginning including from
some of the Strategic Imports but now
we're seeing signs that this Imports are
still reaching Russia but via other
countries so we need to double down on
the implementation of some of the
measures that we have announced
and there have been more measures coming
and more sanctions coming by the day
they seem to be being announced and the
US has just sanctioned one of Russia's
richest men more sanctions coming there
more coming from the EU we'll talk about
the impact they're having on the economy
obviously in Russia but also on the
European and U.S economies and one of
the ways to measure the health of an
economy is to look at the value of its
currency low so let's just see how
Russia's Ruble and the Euro have fared
since the invasion of Ukraine back in
February let's begin with the Russian
currency with these graphs remember that
low is basically a good thing and you
can see here that in the months after
the invasion the number of rubles to the
dollar actually fell recently it's been
lingering around the 60 to the dollar
Mark and the ruble is arguably in better
shape than it was in before the war but
let's also take a look now at the Euro
and how that's been doing it's had a
noticeably tougher time of it at one
point it actually hit parity with the
dollar something that hadn't happened
since the very early days of The single
currency however it's recovered somewhat
since that point
how much can we read into the apparent
resilience of the ruble in in the face
of these sanctions
well as one of the sort of insiders said
there is nobody has done more damage to
the Russian budget than the governor of
the Central Bank and I'll explain it now
uh most a big chunk of Revenge is 40 of
Russian federal budget revenues come
from oil and gas exports so the
company's export get dollars so Euros
back in return they convert them into
rubles and then pay their taxes to the
Russian budget so what happens when the
ruble goes from 150 to 65 budget loses
trillions of rubles and revenues so it's
not as you can see it's not a one-way
Street saying well strong currency is
great and and we currency is not for
Russian Central Bank and I mean
particularly the ministry fine and
strong Ruble is a big problem at the
moment they would love to see it weaker
unfortunately it's hard when you have
pretty much blocked your financial
account you prevent people from
withdrawing money from the country
foreign investors and at the same time
you're having a large current account
Surplus basically the trade balance is
in large Surplus so that brings me to
the second point on the on the train
battle Islands we talk a lot about
sanctions Russia is the most sanctioned
economy now in the world but let's not
forget until 5th of December we have not
yet touched the Crown Jewel we haven't
touched the exports of energy and gas
and I think that's why for now Russia
enjoyed large foreign exchange inflows
it will continue to change next year for
Europe it's definitely a nuanced picture
Europe relied for many guests on a
relatively cheaper energy supplies from
Russia and of course also pursuing
multiple objectives of course very
important ones green deal is a very
important objective but it also meant
that some of the Strategic suppliers to
Europe felt that they would like to
switch to short-term energy contracts
with Russia which was Europe sorry which
of course much more volatile so Europe
needs to reassess its strategic
objectives and priorities but also
finally let us not forget that sanctions
is one way but at the same time we're
having war basically on the territory of
Europe and other countries are
potentially also at risk of Russian
aggression So Physical War versus some
pain from sanctions this is the cost
benefit analysis we need to make
and just to go back to the the currency
question and talk about the Euro a
little bit how much has the behavior of
the Euro been dictated by
um
European sanctions against Russia and
how much of it is actually just down to
the you know the war itself
well I think it's uh it's important to
say that for Europe gas prices are very
important for the U.S you know to
simplify somewhat oil prices are more
important so therefore as we had
concerns of skyrocking skyrocketing cash
prices I'm sorry even before the war of
course there were concerns about
European competitiveness European
economy and also the fact that the
commodity prices I get paid in dollar so
I think that had an impact on euro
dollar relationship of course now as the
situation is stabilizing we see Europe
holding up somewhat better of course
that is again impacting uh euro dollar
relationship when Europe is Europe is
weaker rather than other countries
countries currencies of course it hurts
us on the inflation fund because there
is a pass through to inflation but at
the same time it makes European exports
somewhat more attractive so as the
global economy begins to stabilize
including China we could actually
potentially benefit from weaker Europe
rather than not
okay Elena I just want to move on
something that's tangentially attached
to to the the currency question and
that's inflation and inflation has been
a word closely associated with the
Russian war in Ukraine so let's look at
how Rising costs have played out in
Russia as compared to the West well in
Russia inflation nearly doubled in the
early months of the war having already
been at 9.2 to a high level is still
above pre-war levels now in the Eurozone
inflation has been lower but steadily
Rising since February it hit double
digits in October and November but it is
showing signs of slowing and in the US
you can see here inflation has been
hovering between seven and nine percent
with a bit of a call off recently
so when it comes to inflation Elena yeah
has has I mean has the war made a bad
situation for Russia worse
I think the war made the bad situation
for Russia definitely worse but of
course also for the global economy it
definitely made the situation worse
um sort of to put it in a bigger context
Emerging Markets started getting worried
about inflation on the back of return
from covet right that's where the
origins of inflation come from
um the emerging markets were more
worried about inflation expectations
including the Central Bank of Russia and
as you know started hiking much before
this time around than the fed or the ECB
at the same time the FED in the ACB felt
that some of the shocks or some people
in this institutions felt that the
shocks are transitory you know this is
just the supply shock and therefore we
could look through it however as they
increasingly realized that inflation
expectations are getting at the risk of
unanchoring of course with so decisive
action by the fed and the ACB so yes the
war made already difficult situation of
coming out of covet harder because it
was an additional unexpected supplies
shock on the energy front
well EU leaders remain committed to
intensifying their sanctions against
Russia don't they Elena I just want to
play a clip because as long as the war
continues these sanctions are going to
keep on coming according to the EU and
after the EU announced its latest
measures this week Olaf Schultz the
chancellor here in Germany said it was
in the Russian President's power to end
the paying back home
with his War Putin is not only
destroying the infrastructure the cities
and Villages of Ukraine
he's not only destroying an incredible
number of human lives and he has not
only put the lives of many of his own
soldiers at risk
because that is also part of the truth
that countless people have died for this
imperialist attempt to take over part of
his neighbor's territory
but actually he's also destroying
Russia's future with this war
and that is what he has to justify to
his own country and his own people whose
future he is damaging in this way
meanwhile in the face of yet more
sanctions against in his regime here's
what President Putin had to say this
week
the sanctions over the first nine months
of this year deliveries of basic goods
from Russia to the EU countries
increased one and a half times
joint Russian exports increased by 42
percent while the trade surplus
increased in our favor by 2.3 times to
138 billion dollars
in essence the European Union continues
to consume our goods and services while
holding back the reverse flows
the situation concerning these
imbalances cannot continue indefinitely
so what do we do we will look for other
more promising Partners in actively
growing regions of the world economy
Asia the Middle East Latin America
Africa
the markets belonging to friendly
countries will be where we will
reorientate Russian energy supplies
already over the first nine months of
this year oil exports to partner
countries increased by almost a quarter
Vladimir Putin with plenty to say there
but he's using this line about how you
know as well as shooting themselves in
the foot he's saying that the European
nations are still but you know helping
to fund Russia with uh with their
purchases of oil and gas although
obviously there are limits on those now
is there any truth in what he's saying
there or is it all propaganda
well the fact that we didn't touch
immediately the sort of the crown jewel
oil and gas I think that means that you
know European Union needed time to
gather domestic support and also prepare
the economy for their spillovers you
know rather the spillbacks from the
sanctions effect exactly what we're
discussing now so I think the
governments needed time to prepare their
population and also measures that they
can do to alleviate the effect of the
sanctions so yes in that sense you know
it's accurate that the current account
is huge because uh European countries
and and many others continue to buy
Russian oil which is no longer will be
the case from the 5th of December and
another important point I think to make
here is that it's not only Europe and
U.S are suffering you know in many
countries for example in Africa there's
been starvation already before and now
Putin was this failed grain deals and
sort of trying to blame the west and the
sanctions rather than the war on Ukraine
which is a very important supply of
global grain and other food products is
making an impact not just on Europe and
the us but also the most sort of the
weaker Frontier economists especially
the vulnerable population there and then
finally if the war is going so well for
Putin why is it that he is more than
doubling spending on their domestic
security So within the current budget
the largest increase is happening in the
domestic security basically it is Amon
or Special Forces to prevent Russian
people from rising and potentially
changing the government so it you know
I'm not political analyst so I'm not
sure I do not know how likely it is to
happen but all I can say that in the
budget people are worried and they're
putting extra money there it's not
Environmental Protection which is
getting cut it's not social spending
which is standing flat and it's been cut
since 2014. it is domestic security and
defense of the Russian government
yeah so there does seem to be some
nerves about what's to come for for the
crown and let's actually talk about uh
the future so we've had signs this week
particularly from the actions of as you
mentioned the Federal Reserve and the
European Central Bank taking a bit of a
step back with their rates increases
increasing by a little less than they
have been doing in the past inflation
seems to be stabilizing if not going
down depending on which side of the
Atlantic you're on are the effects of
the sanctions that the West have imposed
on Russia diminishing as we get further
and further away from the moment when
those sanctions were imposed and
actually taking less of a toll on the
countries that imposed them
I think it's the combination of the fact
as we talked about sort of the
post-covered recovery the central banks
in the the merge in developed markets
the federal ECB I would say being
somewhat behind the curve when they
started and then on top of that the
effect of sanctions I think all of these
effects are diminishing and which should
see stabilization and inflation and also
coming off partially of course because
of the base effects so the after
decisive actions of the fed and ACB
early on now they actually have a bit
more space to be a bit more patient so I
yes the effect of the sanctions is
diminishing somewhat but also other
effects like being behind the curve and
also the post-covered recovery and the
effect on inflation
okay and as for Russia is the worst of
the sanctions still to come for them is
there more pain down the road are they
they're yet to really bite
pain is going to be continuous you know
we've seen immediate impact and I have
to say I do not believe all of the
Russian statistics for example this year
they're reporting double-digit
investment growth of course supposedly
governments did double digit investment
the state control companies did double
the digit investment I find it very hard
to believe though some of those numbers
nonetheless the impact will continue to
be medium term at the same time as
Russia finds new creative ways to
circumvent sanctions we need to have to
be aware that this is almost like a game
of whack-a-mole we need to keep coming
after different actors whether it's
third countries that are not directly
involved in sanctions and find also
creative ways that will help the
industry not only just the financial
industry but the insurance industry the
shipping industry to comply with the
sanctions and there again what we
started talking about is the
implementation
um is the key at the moment
okay I think that's a good place to
leave it just looking ahead at how what
2023 is perhaps going to look like so I
will say thank you very much Alina
ribakova deputy chief Economist at The
Institute of international finance for
joining us on this DW business special
thank you so much for having me
and if you've enjoyed watching this
wherever you are watching it there's
plenty more from DW business here on the
DW news YouTube channel until next time
take care